the average u.s household consumes about
11 000 kilowatt hours of electricity a
year
the biggest share of that power about 16
goes to this
air conditioning summer months bring
higher temperatures and higher
electricity bills but a wall street
journal analysis found you could be
paying more than your neighbors to keep
your house cool
and may not even know it even if the
power is generated in the same exact
place
and transmitted on the same exact power
[Music]
lines
to understand how this happens first you
need to understand how power gets to
your house
power plants generate electricity the
voltage is cranked up at a substation
and sent across long distance
transmission lines
crank down again then sent through
distribution lines that connect to your
home
in many cases everything from the plant
to the power poles are owned by a
regulated utility company
they supply you with the power and bill
you for how much you use
government officials let the utilities
charge enough to cover costs
and make a modest profit but high
electricity prices cost regulators to
re-examine this model
the big question um that drove a lot of
the thinking
in the 1980s around electricity and
and deregulation or restructuring was
did the whole system have to be a
monopoly or could there be
pieces of the electricity ecosystem
parts of how electricity is
generated moved over wires and then
supplied ultimately to customers
that could be competitive businesses and
kind of broken off
deregulation was in vogue from railroads
to telecommunications and the energy
market was no exception
it opened up to allow for companies to
compete to sell power to homes and
businesses
these new entities known as retail
energy companies
would buy electricity from generators
and sell it to consumers
usually over the local utilities wires
the argument for deregulation went that
giving consumers a choice between their
old utilities and new rivals would
create competitive pricing
and lower their bills eventually at
least 18 states deregulated retail
residential electricity to varying
degrees
but in many of them the promise savings
haven't materialized
according to a wall street journal
analysis between 2010 and 2019
u.s consumers who signed up with retail
energy companies paid 19.2 billion
dollars more
than they would have if they stuck with
their incumbent utilities
retail customers have paid the most in
texas which deregulated its energy
market the furthest
this system came under intense scrutiny
after a february 2021 winter storm
crippled its power grid
and left many texas residents with
electric bills that sort into the
thousands of dollars
electricity deregulation has worked for
business federal data show it led to
substantial savings for commercial and
industrial power customers whose
large-scale electricity use
give them the incentive to shop around
and seek expert guidance
the retail power industry largely
languished until about a decade ago
when many states adopted a regulation
called purchase of receivables
that made the traditional utility
companies solely responsible for unpaid
bills
experts have said that because they were
no longer responsible for unpaid bills
retail power companies didn't have to
worry about the risk of signing up lower
income consumers
there are often many many
variations in the kind of electricity
contract that you might sign with a
retail provider
just as for cell phone contracts you
might be negotiating about data
and minutes and you know
other bells and whistles that might come
with a contract that might increase its
attractiveness
a second really important similarity
has to do with the sort of central role
that
getting customers plays in the business
model of retail electricity
providers experts say retail energy
sales people often go door to door and
offer perks for switching to their
service such as gift cards or
free light bulbs many states have
investigated retail providers marketing
tactics that target elderly and poor
customers
as well as heavily minority
neighborhoods where electricity bills
account for larger shares of income
a 2018 illinois lawsuit said an energy
retailer carried out a particularly
egregious marketing scheme
that disproportionately impacted
african-american consumers on the south
and west side of chicago
and an analysis of the connecticut
retail power industry revealed that
retail power customers receiving state
assistance to cover electricity costs
known as hardship customers paid
premiums that were on average nearly 50
percent higher than other customers for
retail providers
susan baldwin an independent consultant
for public utilities and consumer
advocates
says some retail companies have
questionable marketing tactics with
aggressive sales pitches aimed at
enrolling customers
it shows disproportionate harm to those
who can least afford to pay for an
essential service this is not a luxury
item this is electricity
part of the problem is that many
consumers don't know who is selling them
their power
in most states that allow competitive
electricity markets for residential
customers
bills are provided by the incumbent
utility company even if the power is
delivered by a retail supplier
the identity of the retailer is
disclosed somewhere on the bill
but it isn't always obvious here's one
way to check if you're paying more for
power
look for the part of the bill that
details price comparison information
there you should find the price for the
so-called standard offer service
or sos for one kilowatt hour of
electricity
that is the average rate charged by the
incumbent utility
next look for how much your electric
supplier charged for that billing period
which is often reported alongside the
name of the company
take the rate your electric supplier
charged and multiply it by the number of
kilowatt hours used
to get the amount paid to the retail
supplier
to figure out the difference between
what you paid to the supplier
and what you would have paid to your
utility multiply the sos rate by the
kilowatt hours used and subtract that
amount from the amount paid to the
supplier
big retail companies can see that there
has been some bad behavior in the market
and that the industry needs to improve
its reputation
and industry backers say residential
customers need better education from the
industry and regulators
on how the retail electricity market
works and how it can benefit them
consumers can take advantage of the
deregulated marketplace by strategically
shifting to suppliers with the lowest
prices
but that can require reading their
contracts fine print
consumer advocates also encourage
customers to scrutinize their bill
and report any potential wrongdoing and
consumers can always switch back to
their incumbent utility provider
if you look at your bill and it seems to
be through the rule
and it's not what you were led to
believe you were told one thing
about rates being wonderfully low and
they end up being
terribly high call your
public utility commission and complain
retail power was supposed to be a light
bulb moment for the energy industry
but the cost of keeping that light bulb
on appeared to be higher than
they could be